so the talk for today is why should you
care about types the agenda is first of
all why is typing important in modern
Python code bases then I'll give a brief
intro about what typing would look like
these days this is obviously not a
hundred percent of features available by
it's more of like the least the smallest
number of feature that you need to be
productive with with typing then I'll
cover types in the real world how do you
start typing a new project and then the
most common these days in industry how
do you add types an existing large a
large project and last but not least a
lessons learned the first three chapters
are more about Weiss typing great and
why should you use it the fourth one is
like I want them quickly some of the
bits that are still missing in the whole
ecosystem and how to get around them
until they get fixed okay so let's
address the questions from the title
first why should you care about about
types I mean one could say that Putin
has been running fine without any typing
information for a really long time so
what we suddenly need to turn into Java
or another statically typed language
well that's all true I think two key
aspects that changed over the last
decade is the amount of people writing
Python code and the size of single
projects in Python so if you think like
how byte and start that it was like
first of all scripting language for C
sobs and automation then Django flask
and beta meat came around so suddenly
Python became a reasonable Trek
alternative to PHP the next step
function was with
numpy and us and all the mathematic
utilities vitam suddenly became the tool
of choice for all data scientists and
other engineers and then even on top of
that ml libraries like psychic learners
were built that made machine learning
more accessible than ever before so the
point I want to make with with this is
that the popularity of Python has grown
really massively over the last decade so
the amount of people reading Python code
has also gone up with that so it's more
important than ever that we uphold like
the key values of why python is so great
which is mostly kind of like it's easy
to write and easy to read when I teach
the Python 101 class at Facebook for
engineers one of the things that really
stress out is like the right code ones
but then that code will be read by other
engineers at least five to ten times
just to review the poor request so we
should be optimizing for the read case
not for the right case and that's what
Python is so great the the second point
was about the growing size of Python
code bases like take Instagram for
example largest jungle up in the world
millions and millions of miles of code
so adding type annotations there is not
so much about the typesafe to the type
checker and like more integration
testing it's just about making engineers
more productive because it's easier to
read to read the code so what we try to
illustrate that on one example imagine
you started working at a new company and
you get assigned a ramp-up task to
improve logging of some job scheduling
code the engineer they prepare the task
points the snippet as the best place to
to get started so your task is to just
log more attributes for each is job
summation so the first thing you need to
figure out is like what this job's
argument actually is so how can you do
that well first of all you can just look
at the code around it so jobs obviously
needs to be some kind of a trouble since
there's a for loop or it
and then from the code we know that each
job has a name and a meta attribute an
intern knows about the priority we job
so one way of finding the code for what
the job type is would be to actually
grab for it right even know how to use
unix tooling it's easy to search for a
class called job the problem in large
code base is that that will yield
thousands over result if it's too small
that's over a thousand that's a real
example from the Facebook back-end
repo from few months ago so just
wrapping four things usually does not
yield good results
another problem with it is that oh sorry
so another way of finding how jobs look
like is to look for how they are
constructed so if you know where the
submit function is called you can go
from there and then figure out how the
jobs are constructed one of the problems
there is all you do not know if it's
called
as module name but submit or its use the
more common like from scheduler input
submit so again we're gonna have to
search the codebase for both quite
time-consuming but it's doable if we
actually manage to find a good example
of a submit function being called then
again like the argument construction
will not be super trivial again you
might need a large code base to do like
ten jumps away until we figure out
exactly how the objects are created so
what else what else can we try one
option is to expect his back tights at
runtime so we can use the print function
to print the the type of each job at
runtime and you can also use the deer
built-in function to actually scan for
all the attributes of the job and this
kind of solves the problem of like
figuring out what other things we could
log with with every job the problem we
though it's quite clunky every time you
need to figure out what the type of
something is you need to put in
Stroman tation in restart your server
you need to make sure that the request
that you send to the server will trigger
that specific part of the code which in
large code bases honestly can be more
tricky than you than you'd imagine and
another problematic aspect with this is
that the experience of an engineer does
not really play at all so it can be a
super senior or junior and just out of
university those prints will work
exactly the same so it's hard even like
with experience to be better to be
better this so there has to be a better
way right and this is where typing comes
into play so typing solves the issue of
making it obvious at first glance what
the input and output pairs of our
function are the productivity win here
is is pretty high because when you want
to inspect the type of something you can
usually just click through if you're
using a modern IDE like pycharm or vs
code usually just comment click on the
argument type will immediately bring it
with the definition of of that class
which compared to all other options we
looked at it's way faster so having more
readable code actually also helps
massively to avoid new engineers and
next thing I want to talk about is how
this drastically helped me scale my team
at Facebook while I was still working on
on testing front our code was in Python
so here there is one specific that
Facebook has bootcamp so when you're
hired for a company you're not hired for
a team you're hard for an office so say
you join the New York office and then
you're gonna have
about six weeks to figure out which team
you want to join so basically all teams
compete for talent to try to convince
engineers to join them so every new
engineer takes a few tasks from teams
they like and then figure out like which
one they like best and then join the
team you can think of these as having
tons of open source projects that you
can can pick from and you have three
weeks to explore them and maybe sends a
few some the few pull requests at the
end you need to decide kind of like
which one you like best
and want to continue contributing long
term so it turns out that when engineers
are productive they are way more likely
to join your team because people like
getting stuff done from from day one and
if they have type information about your
code the barrier of entry for starting
doing something useful is actually much
lower than if the code is without types
especially on huge code bases as our own
and we're back in these mono repo so you
can imagine how big it is and as I said
this applies to to open source pretty
well in my opinion the three key concept
to like have an open source project real
quickly are good getting started
documentation typed code that's easy to
easy to understand and easy to get
started by sending a pull request and
automated testing in CI if you have
those three key components in place I've
seen quite a few projects just like very
organically getting new contributors
well other projects are more complex to
get started usually to rely on getting
people up to speed in spins which is
also fair strategy okay the next
question I want a dress is are Python
types by tonic
when other engineers at Facebook here
are very passionate about having fully
typed Python code bases the usual
reaction is something along the line
oh nice pythons turning into Java and
it's going to have the same fate as you
are so let's try to answer these
next up item types platonic I think the
answer is yes and a good strategy to
figure out if something's pythonic is to
look at the sign of python which you get
to by importing this I think in this
case there are three key points that
supports typing which is explicit is
better than implicit readability counts
and in the face of ambiguity I refuse
the temptation to guess especially the
last one I think like is very strongly
for typing because if the type of
something was obvious when you wrote the
code ideal if you go back after a week
and read the code again it should be
obvious still I cannot tell you how many
times I've seen things like ID or
transaction ID or user ID and I had no
idea if it was a string or an integer
because we do not enforce it across the
code base so usually you have to start
your server and figure out like how in a
production example what type it is which
is super slow if this is not enough also
get a said so before he retired from
being dependable and dictator for life
so you can take his word for it as well
the second question is in spite and
turning into Java or C++ or any other
statically typed language and the answer
here is definitely no it's definitely
inspired by other languages and I guess
we've taken the best bits and pieces
from other people that made mistakes
before us and learn from them in Python
typing is still very much optional you
can use it you cannot use it you can use
it partially you can use it or you think
it's useful so it's completely up to the
developer and the team to figure out how
they want to use it another key aspect
is that typing has no impact at runtime
ideally there is a cost you pay for
importing the typing module but you pay
that only at server startup time so
hopefully it's not it's not an issue for
the vast majority of projects and the
last but not least type errors can be
ignored which is usually not the case in
any other statically typed language so
in C++ if you're on GCC to compile the
code if there's an error there's no way
of silencing that error we need to fix
it and recompile in Python that that's
not the case okay so let's look at
typing one on one set of features you
need to know to get started with with
typing so as everything Python is good
to know like how it got how it started
and in this case there are two tabs that
are of relevance
the first one is PAP 3107 all the way
back from 2006 that defined the syntax
for annotating functions but did not
define that that needs to be typing so
anything any useful functional notation
could be still used today
then the fab that you are most familiar
with if you use typing before is app 404
called sty pins from 2014 the authors
are really well-known people so neither
himself yucca which is the author of my
poem the first item type checker and
Mukesh Langer which was to be a
colleague of mine in the London office
and is now responsible for their list of
3.8 and 3.9 so type ends basically give
the blueprint of how to make typing work
in Python how to make the semantics work
and how to allow people to build type
checkers
so my PI walk being like the most
commonly used type checker it's not the
item type checker it's just one of the
potent objectors and in the spirit of
the previous map so 3107 if you find a
new use case for functional notations
you are still very free to use them so
if you have a great idea on how to
exploit them it's still compatible with
map 404 484 for for typing's ok so let's
look at what needs to be to be annotated
in this case we have my print function
that takes a message and just printed
with some formatting
and square it has an interaction that
probably takes the the length of the
size so if you look at how the type
version of this code looks like it's
like pretty close to what I just
described so we have a my print function
that takes a message which is a string
and returns none since there's no
explicit term statement and the init
method of the square accepts an INT
could have been a float as well and by
definition all in it functions have to
return none okay so what are things to
be annotated in some cases variables so
this is not the case as in like other
static type language with every single
variable needs to start with the types
like int counter equal to zero so in
this case but all type checkers are
smart enough to figure out from the
context what the type of something is
when they usually need help is when you
have an empty collection initialized
somewhere and then you fill it up
elsewhere so the type checker is not
like smart enough to figure out all the
possible code paths and figure out what
the type of a dictionary is so in those
cases when you initialize the dictionary
I need to tell type checker okay this is
going to be a dictionary with string
keys and integer values this syntax with
the colon of the variable name works
only in 3 6 and up so if you're still
using Python 3 5 or lower you can use
the comment syntax as far as the type
checkers are concerned this is exactly
the same is just a slightly older
version of it ok next let's look at
collections so here we have function
that needs to compute the octave users
per country of our service for example
so the first argument is a list of users
where every element of the list is a top
own that has an integer and string the
integer represents the user ID
and the string represents the name of
the country where this user is based the
second argument is a set of user ID for
our test users because we probably don't
want to be reporting test users in our
stats and the return type was as I was
saying the count very country so the key
of a dictionary is the name of the
country and then the value is the number
of users in that specific country and
that kind of covers all basic
collections you'll be using day to day
invite on so list sets dictionary and
tuples usually don't need much more than
that to be very productive with typing
next let's look at unions unions allow
you to say that at runtime something is
gonna be either type A or type B so in
this case I have an example of a
function that fetches something from a
database given numeric ID say for
example my sequel the idea of the row
that we are fetching from so since we
don't know if the numeric ID is gonna be
for a user or a page in a simplified
Facebook example we basically to tell
the function that the return type is
gonna be harder a user or a page so if I
asked for my own ID ID get back a user
and if I asked for the ID of the Pythons
add a Facebook page I will get baked
back a page you don't trust me on the
numbers you can actually try them
yourself if you go on Facebook calm and
you put this number it actually will
lend you on on the correct page okay but
what happens if I look for an ID that's
not there say like minus one probably is
not a valid row number so in this case
we can just return none so we can amend
our function signature to be a union of
user page and and none this is super
common construct there is actually a
slightly cleaner way of doing it which
is called up
as far as the type checker is concerned
a union with none or an optional exactly
the same thing but semantically it's
slightly better because the explains but
like what the function does which is if
I find an ID I return that object which
can be a user or a page otherwise I
return none if I find if I don't find
anything okay the last key concept I
want to try to explain our type bars the
theory behind them is slightly
convoluted so lets me let me start from
an example again in this case we have
super simple base class in a derived
class that extends the base class and
then we have a factory function that
takes the type of a class and returns
the an instance of of that that same
class so as things are typed currently
so like we type baseball senator in base
class the type checker would think that
regardless of if we pass in base class
or derived course to the factory the
actual output type would always be base
class which works fine enough it's not
wrong but you actually do lose
information it's better to be as
specific as possible with with typing so
we've what we would actually want to get
is for when we call the factory over the
rived class let the type checker know
that that's an instance of the derived
class not to the base course and the
system to make is possible our type VARs
you can think of type for us as kind of
like placeholder for typing information
that once the input is known then the
output is definitely of type of type T
so in this case we define a new type for
the first argument is the name of the
type for which needs to match the
variable name that's a implementation
detail and then we bound this type of
wire to the base class which basically
means we are take T now can represent
anything that's a base class or derived
claustrum from base class so now that
the factory uses the type bar rather
than a hard-coded type it actually would
correctly identify calling the factory
over the derived class as having the
derived type okay
the next important bit is the the type
checker so if you look at the super
simple example we import the math module
and we ask the square root of 100 both
as an integer and and string will expect
it line three to write type error cause
obviously you cannot ask the square root
of a string so here I'm using my pie
since it's the most common type checker
these days so just run my pie and you
point it to your Python file and sure
enough my part is going to say that that
does not work because a security expects
a float the conversion from interested
floats happen happens automatically I
also want to mention wire as an
alternative to my pie for a type
tracking as far as the user is concerned
in terms of like the errors reported and
how it looks in fields it's very very
similar because they're all based on the
same Maps back the main advantage of
Peyer is it's much much faster on large
code bases it was developed by a team at
Instagram because my PI was just getting
too slow for the size of the whole
jungle repo so when it launched about
two years ago my PI took about five
minutes to run the full Instagram
codebase fire took 45 seconds which is
almost not of magnitude faster so for
smaller code bases the difference will
not be as great but from medium to
large-sized the difference can can be
quite quite large and another selling
point for fire is that it was designed
from they want to support incremental
typing so basically if you just add a
new line somewhere and you can you know
save the file
why I don't know there is no need to
retype check the whole application and
spend one minute on that my PI is
getting that features as well but
they're still under under development
like wires it's a pretty strong selling
point if you have a large code base
okay so let's next look at how do you
start using the pipes in in the real
world first let's look at the easy bit
which is for for new projects and
honestly here the recipe is pretty
simple we just ship hundred percent
typed Python code from day one you
enable the type checker in CI because
you do not want all that good work to go
to waste so first of all you want to
prevent from type errors from being
through some the code base but then you
also want to make sure that if the cloud
base was 100% typed it states stays that
way you can think of this similar in a
similar fashion as preventing test rot
so if we had 100% test coverage there
are ways in continuous integration to
make sure that the test coverage does
not go down the same can be done for for
typing and that's really it
once you have your setup in continuous
integration your work is mostly done and
automation will police everything
everything for you let's look now at the
hard part existing / large projects are
honestly in the more common keys in the
industry so a key concept for how to
start typing large projects is the first
understand how gradual gradual typing
work so again let's start from an
example so we're gonna have two Python
files job the py and util dot py and job
depends on own utils and here's the code
for them so utils just has a pretty
print function it basically accepts a
job and prints it nicely formatted as as
jason and then job the py is the one
responsible
or actually create image so if you just
glanced over this code you would
probably expect the type arrow to be
realized because we're passing in a
string where we accept a job type the
thing is this would not cause a type
error because of the logical typing the
create job function is not annotated it
does not have a return type so the type
checker will completely skip the body of
that function this basically allows you
to start typing large code bases without
paying a huge cost for the first few
files so you can imagine if you have
like a hundred Python files and have one
you till that old all the other minds
line depend on if you started typing
something in you till you'd probably get
errors in the other 99 which would make
starting with typing like really hard
and that's why first you'd only type
check util itself and then you to itself
against the next file you start you
start typing so the way for getting this
type error to show to show up is just to
add the return type to to create job and
then sure enough my PI would figure out
that's not the leader type in Boston
okay so let's go back to the recite for
hard project so as I said the easiest
way is to start from the common
libraries the util dot py of your
project because they require the least
cognitive overall to understand what's
going on usually they depend on in
themselves or in the standard library
which is reasonably typed so it should
not be a huge amount of work to figure
out like how the utility is working what
are the input output pairs after that
the same is for the easy bit which I'd
run the type checker make sure
everything's fine
and then we turn on the type checker in
CI because even if you manage to get
only say two percent of the codebase
typed it's still very much worth to make
it to protect two percent stick and make
sure no one else on your team regresses
it
and the fourth point is to ask people to
add types the new code which can be
tricky this depends quite a bit on the
setup of your team at least in my cases
so far code quality and the investments
in code quality were all is well seen
so anything that would improve test
coverage or with ability was always very
well seen so as soon as we started using
typing on the team everyone was very
eager to start like looking at their old
code and see if they could add more and
more types it's also very important for
leadership though to encourage this type
of work because otherwise it's hard to
justify it even if stuck the investment
is small working on this and shipping a
new feature for example and the last the
last trick is to use monkey type which
I'm going to cover next
so monkey type is a utility also
developed by Instagram when they figured
out that for huge code bases you can
rely on engineers to some extent but
just adding type annotations everywhere
it's a pretty tedious job like saying
like this this ID is an integer this ID
is a string so the basic designed system
that can collect types at runtime and
load them then the system takes all
these logs aggregates them figures out
what the signature function should be
and can also apply it back to the code
itself and this can be pretty good to
get like at least the easy part of
typing out of the way I have seen pretty
large projects get from zero percent
type two twenty to forty percent within
one day by using by using my type what
monkey type generates for you are stubs
these are basically files with PI Y high
extension that contain valid Python code
but instead of having the body of each
function they only have the signature
and they have module level variable as
well so in this case I'm showing
the example of the stub from the math
module of the standard library so as you
would expect PI is typed as a float so
3.14 and and so on so how do you use
Monkey type as everything Python you
have to install it then you use the
monkey type run wrapper to basically
start your application by default this
will track types of all function calls
and generate sequel I'd database in the
local directory and then you can ask
monkey type to generate the stub for a
specific module based on all the logs
collected so in the examples I was
showing earlier with pretty print monkey
type will actually say that the job was
a string since well it was the only
example it's sewing in production and
it's also shows kind of like one of the
hidden benefits of monkey type in some
cases some of the generated types can be
really unexpected
and I've found quite a few bugs in our
code base just like relying on this
filling out something we expect not to
be a union is actually Union or the
other way around as well
another added benefit is that if mypie
cannot find the type definition for one
of your functions it's usually a very
good indication that's actually not used
so it's that hole that you could remove
and reduce complexity and loss steps for
a monkey type is just to apply back the
generated stubs to the actual code you
can either keep the type information
inline or int into the PI Y files that's
a basically a decision thumper project
usually I prefer inline
types for new projects and for existing
ones it's sometimes easier to keep them
keep them separate in another repo
another thing to note here though is
that this unfortunately cannot be done
for a hundred percent of production
traffic inspecting all function calls is
as you can imagine very expensive
so the solution at the incident did for
this was to basically sub sample
randomly 1% of incoming production
traffic and then run them for this
specialty of servers that had type
collection on that did not degrade
performance too much and still got very
realistic traffic to to gather the
typing information ok and the last
section is about lessons learned over
the last three years I've been using
Python typing quite extensively the the
first one I want to cover is duck typing
in the new statically typed we're like
where is it will the Ducks end up going
I guess you all know the famous if it
looks like a duck swims like a duck and
quacks like a duck it's probably a duck
so how do we make that work with
statically typed information at first
glance does not seem super super
compatible so here we have a function
called duck things that accepts dock
returns none and then just calls quack
and swim over the duck object then let's
say we have two examples ferry dock and
gecko duck
so both like look reasonable to both
quack and swim this is what it look like
but the type checker would not be too
happy with this obviously because they
do not extend dark directly although at
run time it would be totally fine
because they can both walk and swim so
how do we reconcile this basically code
that's fine at runtime but the type
checker isn't happy with the solution to
that is called protocols it's not yet in
the standard typing module because it's
still a tiny bit experimental so you
have to be to install typing extensions
in my experience though we've never seen
any issues with it in production so it
works perfectly fine and it's likely to
be used to be used today
so with protocols we can now define a
dock that
quacks and flies and you see the three
dots after the d function signature
that's the same as in stops it's
basically skipping the body of the Audi
function so with protocols we basically
instead of expressing a class extending
something we express the looks like
attribute so now that duck thing except
a duck which is a protocol anything that
looks like a duck will be type checked
fine fine as well and it's quite
interesting that Python supports this
now because duck typing makes Python so
fast and easy in easy to write but it
still can't reconcile this of being able
to use both structural subtyping which
is what you would know from axial force
in Java so we say like a extends from B
implements C while also supporting
behavioral subtyping which is basically
this protocol thing of like an object
needs to be able to do something rather
than looking at inheritance of it next
is the type shot which caused me quite a
few headaches when I started typing our
code base so if you end up finding
typing here against a module in the
standard library and you try to look at
the types for its standard library it's
actually interesting that the types are
not in the code they're in a separate
repo called the type shed which still
sits under the Python umbrella on github
but the reason it's done
that way is to make the type information
be able to evolve much faster and not be
bound to the Python release schedule so
that errors can be fixed much much much
faster another in one's point in the
story is that the type shot is usually
bundled with your type checker so if you
have two different type checkers
installed in on your machine they're not
necessarily using the same version of
the of the type shot which can honestly
be quite confusing
in some cases especially if you're
trying to show that my by umpire catch
the same things the type shot is still
very much far from perfect so if you
find a blog please send the pull request
usual the contributors are super super
responsive and you can get the thanks
from from Gita himself you know he's the
one approving the pull requests there
and what notable modules they still are
like a bit behind our multi-threading
and multi processing so if you want to
contribute I would start looking from
there next we have type ignore and I
mentioned before this is like the in the
weird situation if you come from from
C++ where you cannot tell the compiler
to shut up and let you compile it
there's a type there in Python you can
actually do that and not all type errors
are necessarily evil partially because
we have the system for skipping type
errors partially because the whole
ecosystem is still kind of in beta so
there are are like known issues and
things that don't don't work well I'll
have an example and sample in a bit so I
had this discussion feels like about you
know a half ago with with ghido about
how should we type internals of specific
or specific modules and his point was
that the type should at least the typing
information for the standard library so
should almost act as documentation for
it rather than having every single
internal variable type checked correctly
the discussion started from from this
piece of code which is quite a bit to
look at on a slide but basically the I
was building the time out to basically
stop waiting on on a queue with a scene
and there is an implementation detail if
the join up join method is already
called on the queue even if your eyes
an exception in that thread it still
does not wake up and is still waiting on
the cue to resolve first so basically my
fix for that was when the timeout fired
used this callback on blood cue callback
which would basically get the lock of
the cue and just release the lock so
that the cue would yield back on throat
the main thread and the main thread
could process the exception from the
timeout the problem was that the cue
module did not have this all tasks done
on lock type checked correctly and
that's the one I want to add in the pull
request or showing and Geeta was against
it he preferred like just airing these
two type ignores comment to skip to skip
the lines entirely because he did not
feel it was useful to introduce such
like low-level implementation detail
into the type stop stem themselves okay
next let's look at how to handle Jason's
in the statically typed or this is
another one that's like very very tricky
so if we start these examples and start
building our JSON type we can first look
at the primitives so okay a JSON
primitive is a union of an integer a
float the string and none in this case
we've covered all examples so next let's
see numbers has to be a list so we can
define jason lists as a list of
primitives and then we have objects like
the one our y equals true so in this
case we say okay like JSON object is a
dictionary with string keys and a union
the value can be a primitive if you look
at the x case it can be jason list if
you look at numbers but then it can be a
nested object if you look at the object
case and this is usually when all type
checkers go kaboom so these cases
currently
not supported and it'll be anytime soon
so unfortunately there is no reasonable
way currently to express the currency of
typing structures so the best way
currently available for type checking
JSON is just defining them as
dictionaries of strings and Annie has AZ
value which does bring a tiny bit of
value and there's a you know that's like
needs to be a dict and he'll buy strings
but otherwise like pretty pretty low
it makes hard to reason about JSON code
as well so a better strategy of how to
handle JSON in a statically typed world
is called named double which is a new
class in in the typing module that
allows you to very quickly prototype
classes that are immutable and in type
safe so in this case we create a blob
which is kind of like the one-to-one
mirror to our JSON blob we say okay X is
an optional float then we have numbers
which is list of integers and we have
object that's a dict
from string to end and then we just have
to provide a manually created class
method to parse the JSON blob and
actually create the named top version of
this of the same blob the advantage of
this approach is if you have to do it
only once so basically as soon as you
get the JSON from the wire you can cast
it to an int Apple and then from there
on you always work with the type
structure which is easier to understand
easier to read and also has the benefit
of being immutable so you cannot change
things by mistake okay that's it let me
just recap what you learned today
so first of all type annotations are
protonic not just because I say so but
because Gita says so you should start
using them for the readability when
definitely
get the extra safety and automation from
a type checker almost almost for free
for new projects it's pretty easy just
start from day one make sure that
continuous integration is set up and
you're good to go for the harder part
existing large code bases thanks to the
other typing you can start very small
and not have a huge investment you can
type two or three files send it for your
team to review see what they think and
by using monkey type you can actually
bootstrap a large amount of typing
information we are doing too much work
for our back-end services in Python are
very commonly seen monkey type do a very
reasonable job for 20 to 30 percent of
typing information based on only like a
few hours of production data and last
avoid using JSON blobs directly cuz it's
code that's usually hard to understand
and very often breaks if a key suddenly
becomes unavailable and try to use named
tuples instead all the code all the cost
lipids really slides as well as the
slides themselves already on my github
if you want to check them out and that's
all I had for today thank you very much
thanks so much Luka I really like that
slide transition when you had Guido said
so find an appropriate thing that's
relevant for the benevolent director for
life a word of warning the juice on your
table isn't juice
it's cordial I found this out the hard
way please take care for goodness sake
so it's question time so we're gonna
have some people roaming around with
mics so if you have some questions let's
get started some interesting things that
came out of that talk quite amazing was
I don't know if you heard but Instagram
uses Django for their back-end which is
pretty [ __ ] incredible and monkey
type looks amazing I can't wait to
actually check that out on github all
right do we have some floating mics
anyway all right go ahead
thank you for the great talk it's great
pleasure to know that many many people
understand that typing is very great
YouTube to grow output ability in code
base and great help this task
my question is regarding typing
dictionaries we have heavy ETL
application and we can you can't take I
had to wrap up in named Apple or some
class and report on our end is there any
solutions to this problem maybe might be
or Pierre can introduce Dictionary
typing in the future what we use
internally to solve that problem is
usually dark losses so we would express
our business logic in terms of dear
classes which are basically the same as
name tuples but mutable
and then there are already built-in
utilities for converting from JSON data
classes and from data classes back to
JSON as well as to drift which we use
internally for for RPC
so in general we don't we try to avoid
using dictionaries directly unless if
they are pretty simple so I would say
anything up to kinda like level two
nested so like a dictionary that has a
dictionaries value that's fine but
anything above that usually makes the
code like really hard to understand for
new people okay thank you thank you for
your talk one of the things I really
like about Python and I think it's
universally loved is readability but
when I saw your example of annotating
the dunder init method returning none I
thought I hope I never have to review
that but if I understood you correctly
type checking will be disabled if we
don't do that
is there a style emerging of where we
can say please do not imitate absolutely
everything so that we don't get to
annotate every dunder init with
returning none since by definition what
it's going to return you know it's part
of the language spec isn't it that's
that's a very good point the
counter-argument to that one would be
from the zen of python again explicit is
better than implicit so yes none is
always returned implicitly from from all
Python functions if you don't have a
return statement
but the typing annotations went with the
D line of like making it more
straightforward so this is a tiny bit
more verbose I I completely agree with
it but I don't think there was any
discussion recently about getting rid of
the non for init functions it might make
sense because they're like very specific
but for other functions that really like
return nothing I think it's available to
have that information there explicitly
in terms of typing everything that's
definitely not necessary and it's
sometimes even really hard
things notably have like very hard hard
time typing is things like database
access like my sequel when you do a my
sequel query against the database you
have no idea what you're gonna get back
you know it's again it's a list of
dictionaries with string keys and any
values so like very little information
there directly so you do need to still
do either you just don't type them and
use them as they are or you that's
significantly more time to move them I
to name tuples or two dollar classes
depending if an inability or not but
both both approaches are valid so have a
soft question not a technical one that's
perfectly related to what you're talking
about
so the it's along the lines of
readability and just overall taste
coverage and software engineering best
practices so you've probably found that
Python being so easy to write and being
used in the Darr science fair lot soon
you have people that don't necessarily
have a strong software engineering
background so do you have any
recommendations for teams that don't
necessarily value continues refactoring
improving readability and test coverage
and so on that's a that's a very very
good point I work with data scientists
on on a daily basis and I finished a
very big difference if you're doing a
notebook just to get a number out of it
or a graph out of it or if you're doing
a notebook that you know someone else is
gonna look at the code I would say if if
you know that someone's gonna review
that code then it's better to invest in
the quality and readability but I know
that day to day data science jobs
sometimes I just need a single number
out of my data scientists and they like
do like 200 lines or not just to get me
that number but red code the next day's
not not need anymore
so in that case I complete understand
that
I'll have to be like the nicest thing
ever yeah okay question over here I've
got two questions the first one is
providing issues before with circular
input imports where if we're trying to
add the type annotation and I was
wondering I deal with that and then the
second one is if you've got a local
variable in a simplest function would
you then skip the type checking if it's
like a simple counter integer so for
circular imports there is a known known
issue that comes with with typing the
way of solving it is by using the type
underscore checking variable from typing
module which is basically true only if
you're type checking code in production
to be false
so you basically do F typing dot type
shacking then you do the circle the
imports it would cause a cycle but then
that runs only in type checking mode and
the type checkers are aware of that
problem and know how to fix it so those
import runs only on type checking a not
in production that's that's how you fix
it so I ought to the second question if
you
if it's a local variable in a function
maybe just a counter which you can also
add type to say it's an int over to skip
that I would add the types only if the
type checkers asked me to add type so as
standard I never type variables unless
the type checker complains about it it's
not obvious from from the context that's
that the rows okay so we have time for
one more question if there is one great
I juggle when I run great my question
just has to do with like the development
of the type checkers and stuff that
you've been using have you gotten any
input from I know their teams in
facebook like Sigma which use Haskell
and similarly like structured languages
have you had any input from those teams
in terms of exploring new kinds of types
and ways of approaching this yes I'm not
entirely sure how much of that is public
knowledge but I think I can share that
for example the the team behind Peyer
which is our type checker some people in
there are the people that built h h
which is type checker for for hack and
also i know they talked extensively to
the people that built flow the type
checker for javascript as well so a lot
of that knowledge was including the very
first design draft for for our type
checker okay well that's it I've got one
last question on your protocol slide you
had some really fancy looking ducks or
those do those belong to you yes
when did your penchant for fancy ducks
like five now on my desk we have the
addiction we have the fingers Facebook
that the way to notify other people not
to bother you it's not just headphones
but also putting a duck on top
of your screen the song if I do not dare
to bother me I'm doing important stuff
do not bother me I've got my Ferro duck
do they have like an importance order
like really seriously dude most people
have most people have only one the five
ISM piece of my finger just like
collecting them so I change them
depending on the mood okay cool cool
cool cool well thank you so much Lukey
let's give him a round of applause
[Applause]